scp-049 also known as the plague doctor
is an scp foundation fan favorite this
charming anomalous surgeon can terrify
with a glance and kill with a touch in
terms of his origins his methods and his
thought process around a disease he
calls the pestilence this is one of the
most mysterious scps out there and
thankfully we didn't have to investigate
this one alone we made a community post
asking you the fans of scp explained to
give us your questions and theories
about the good doctor that we all hope
doesn't give house calls and you didn't
disappoint let's grab our masks and hand
sanitizer and take a look at what you
had to say about scps
first the questions bob candle asked why
does he refuse to tell researchers about
the pestilence that's a good question
and also one of the biggest mysteries
surrounding zero four nine's lore for
the uninitiated the pestilence also
known as the great dying is the nickname
given to an unknown disease that
scp-049 has dedicated his life to curing
whatever curing means to him when asked
by foundation researchers 049 refuses to
give up even the most basic information
about the pestilence such as how he
diagnoses it what its effects are or how
it's transmitted it seems that part of
the reason that 049 refuses to tell
researchers about it is that he
apparently assumes that they as fellow
doctors inherently know what he's
talking about when he brings up the
pestilence he is acted with confusion
and frustration during questioning and
049 seems to believe that the pestilence
is such common knowledge among medical
practitioners that it would be a waste
of time to explain it if he even had the
words to do so dadgamer56 asked why is
he so cooperative if humans have the
pestilence he wants to cure so bad one
of the most remarkable things about 049
is how reasonable he's been with
foundation's staff in the past he's
polite friendly and treats his jailers
as equals when he's not murdering them
and turning them into zombies but that
is a good question if he believes humans
have the pestilence why is he so
cooperative with them thankfully the
answer here is simple while 049 believes
that the pestilence is widespread he
doesn't believe that every human is
carrying it in fact when he was first
contained by the foundation and brought
into an scp facility he complemented the
staff on how little pestilence there was
inside the building compared to the
outside while we don't know what lead
049 to think a person is healthy or
diseased we do know there is a
distinction and he's cooperative with
those he sees as healthy stardoggogaming
asked how would he interact with 610 aka
the flesh that hates i wonder if he
would view the infected as pestilence
another great question 610 is an
extremely dangerous sarkic scp that
presents as a zombie-like virus that
causes horrific fleshy mutations because
of the extremely high infection rate of
the flesh that hates it's been
quarantined in its present location in
the isolated siberian wilderness while
it would be too dangerous to bring
anyone or anything into contact with the
flesh we're betting that 049 would find
the flesh utterly repulsive whether even
he would be able to cure this horrific
infection is another question the flesh
that hates is best left alone at all
costs mscipher50 asked
scp-049's notebook appears to be written
in a language no human can decipher
could another scp like 343 or 662 decode
the notebook the answer to this is a
solid
maybe these two scps known as god and mr
deeds respectively may be able to
translate the contents of 049's
mysterious leather-bound notebook the
problem is given that we've seen 049 is
a pretty terrible doctor when it comes
to anything other than raising mutant
zombies from the dead the contents of
his notebook might just be as useless as
the interviews with him have proven to
be that said it probably is worth a try
just to find out if he's actually been
pretending to write this whole time
green angel snake yt asked do other
living creatures like pigs cats or
literally any animal have this thing he
calls the pestilence what even are the
living things he considers cured to the
best of our knowledge 049 only believes
humans can contract the pestilence how
do we know this this leads us to our
next question mia the hot dog asked if
he touches the immortal lizard will the
lizard die and be rid of disease or will
the lizard be immune or will it attack
the doctor the foundation did attempt to
terminate 682 with 049 but the effort
was unsuccessful 049 when encountering
the lizard commented that only humans
can contract the pestilence when he
tried to touch 682 the lizard swiped at
him with its claws 049 then requested to
leave and later interviews revealed that
the plague doctor felt emotionally
disturbed by his time with 682 gamerduck
gamerduckyt asked where did he
originally come from well evidence
suggests that 049 is extremely old and
very well traveled he was first
discovered by the foundation in the town
of montebalm in southern france given
that he speaks fluent medieval french as
his first language it's safe to assume
that france is probably his country of
origin and could have existed for
hundreds of years if not longer
interestingly his famous plague doctor
appearance is more similar to those
first worn by italian doctors in the
17th century which only deepens the
mystery of
scp-049 garrett eborne asked why does he
insist that he isn't doing harm when
he's clearly in violation of his
hippocratic oath zero four nine does
seem to regret the harm he causes but he
also believes that the small sacrifices
are necessary in the quest to cure the
pestilence also a fun little history
lesson given that zero four nine's
knowledge of medicine appears to be
medieval meaning potentially as early as
the 5th century he actually would have
predated the hippocratic oath coming
into universal use by doctors which
didn't become widespread until the 19th
century despite the oath itself first
being created around 400 bc phoenix fane
asked if he has to wear gloves of any
kind would he still kill you all
evidence seems to point to no only skin
to skin contact with 049 is fatal so a
good pair of gloves could really be a
lifesaver alice verdugo asked what would
happen if he went one on one with a shy
guy would he cure him or not do anything
well we can't know for sure because
scp-096 aka the shy guy isn't human it's
likely that 049 wouldn't even consider
him infected if the two came into
contact it would probably result in a
stalemate much like the time
scp-096 faced off against
scp-682 however if it did come to blows
between the two 096 is undeniably a much
more dangerous combatant and may be able
to narrowly defeat the plague doctor in
a direct confrontation while in its rage
state anything goes asked if he died
could he bring himself back to life or
have something prepared to bring himself
back to life like a lot of anomalies it
seems that 049 is abnormally hard to
kill given that he's seemingly
impervious to most physical damage
however seeing as 049's resurrection is
both a lengthy medieval process and
never brings its subjects back correctly
it's likely that if someone could
successfully put 049 down he wouldn't
get back up i'm not coming asked we know
that doctors are wearing masks to
protect patients but is his mask part of
his skull or face all of 049's clothes
including his plague doctor mask are
technically part of his body the mask is
part of its bone structure and the other
clothes are like layers of skin which
leads us nicely to the next question
requiem asked if the clothing around him
is skin does he shed it we're not sure
but it's definitely a thought we all
wish we could forget
oh god now let's take a look at some of
your more interesting theories clarence
i liam theorized pestilence is sin and
he's trying to take it away this is
certainly an interesting theory while we
can't find much in his file that
suggests 049 views the pestilence as a
result of sinful behavior or the concept
of sin itself it's worth considering
that his medical background seems to
come from medieval times medical science
was in its infancy back then and many
still believe that diseases were the
result of loose morals or even demonic
interference so there might be some
truth to this theory thomas has
theorized i feel like he isn't really
bad all he wants to do is help and cure
everyone but his cure is death if we're
defining bad as a malicious desire to
cause harm for its own sake then this
theory holds a lot of water for all
intents and purposes it does seem that
049 does genuinely want to cure his
patience of the pestilence and he does
seem to express remorse when they die
however by his own admission his cure is
imperfect and he hasn't found full
success in curing the disease without
causing death yet cat and dog live
theorized the plague doctor has seen the
end of the world and travels in a loop
back in time aiming to eventually stop
it the pestilence is the way each
human's impact on the end of the world
is and once he touches their flesh they
realize this and die of the realization
of what they've done the plague doctor
may be looking for a human or an scp
that is pestilence-free for what reason
we don't know we don't have an awful lot
to say about this one because there's no
real evidence either way but given that
time travel does seem to be possible in
the scp foundation universe it's a cool
possibility that we definitely can't
rule out it does however leave a lot of
loose ends about the gaps in 049's
knowledge such as the fact he doesn't
know about the black death vladimir
lenin theorized he's the best doctor
ever he cures depression pestilence and
sometimes his patients even come back
from the dead 5 star rating this is
certainly an extremely charitable way to
view
scp-049 one that he himself would likely
very much appreciate however considering
he changes his patience into mindless
zombified mutants a better course of
action may just be to attend therapy
chaotix theorized the pestilence is
death he is literally trying to cure
death well this could be one
interpretation of why 049 resurrects his
patients as zombies death is something
that affects all living non-anomalous
humans and 049 seems to be selective on
which humans it identifies as being
infected with the pestilence as a result
it is unlikely that the pestilence
refers to death itself and death is also
likely a preferable alternative to being
turned into a zombie by 049's
experimental treatments the blue
guardian theorized the pestilence is an
entity in our collective unconsciousness
described in
scp-5000 why
this is an extremely interesting theory
and one that could hold water too if you
check out our series on scp-5000 you'll
find that the foundation discovered a
being known as it hiding inside the
collective unconsciousness of humankind
while the foundation doesn't know about
this in our dimension it's possible that
scp-049
and simply doesn't realize that everyone
is infected with it yet but if this is
the case and scp-049 realizes that the
whole world is infected he's likely to
become a much more dangerous anomaly
that refuses to cooperate with anyone
moonleaf's 4 30 theorized the pestilence
is the foundation and 049 is a disciple
of the scarlet king this is another
incredibly fun theory however there are
two big problems the first is that 049
has historically identified people with
no foundation affiliation as being
infected with the pestilence and the
second even more important issue is that
scp-049 is a highly scientific creature
whereas the scarlet king hates the very
idea of science with a burning passion
as a result
scp-049 and the scarlet king are likely
natural enemies and finally xerathrax
theorized his theme song should probably
be gangsta's paradise it's just a
speculation though on this theory we
wholeheartedly agree and there you have
it thanks to everybody who sent in their
great questions and theories about
scp-049
keep an eye on our community post to see
what anomalous entity we need your
thoughts on next got an scp you'd really
like us to cover in a video like this in
the future let us know down in the
comments and remember to stay safe and
healthy because if you start feeling a
little under the weather you can expect
a visit from
scp-049 sometime soon now check out
scp-096 look at a picture of the shy guy
in space the shy guy questions and
theories and scp-082
fernand the cannibal for more foundation
mysteries unraveled